alright let's get started so today's
lecture is going to be on logic to
motivate things I want to start with a
hopefully easy question so if X 1 plus X
2 is 10 and X 1 minus X 2 is 4 what is X
1 someone shout out the answer once you
hear that 7 so how did you come get 7
yeah you do the algebra thing that you
learned a while ago right so what's the
point of this so notice that this is a
factor graph right we have two variables
they're connected by two constraints or
factors and you could in principle go
and use backtracking search to try
different values of X 1 and X 2 until
you eventually arrive at the right
answer but clearly this is not really an
efficient way to do it and somehow in
this problem there's extra structure
that we can leverage to arrive at the
answer in a much much easier way and
this is kind of their going to be the
poster child of what we're going to
explore today and on next Monday's
lecture how you can do logical inference
to arrive an answer is much faster than
your white house so we've arrived at the
end of the class and I want to just
reflect a little bit on what we've
learned and maybe this will be also a
good review for the exam so in this
class we've bolts bolts did everything
on the modeling inference learning
paradigm and the picture you should have
in your head is this abstractly we take
some data we perform some learning on it
and we produce a model and using that
model we can produce a perform inference
which looks like taking in a question
and returning an answer so what does
this look like for all the different
types of instantiations we've looked at
so for search problems the model is a
search problem and the inference asks a
question what is a minimum cost path in
MVP
in games we asked a question what is the
maximum value policy and csps we asked
the question what is a maximum weight
assignment and a Bayesian networks we
can answer probabilistic inference
queries of the form what is the
probability of some query variables
conditioned on some evidence variables
and for each of these case we looked at
the modeling we look at the the
inference algorithms and then we looked
at different types of learning
procedures going backwards maximum
likelihood we looked at various
reinforcement learning algorithms we
looked at structure perceptron and so on
and hopefully this this kind of sums up
the kind of the world view that so
yesterday one is trying to impart is
that there are these different you know
components and depending on what kind of
modeling you choose you have different
types of algorithms and learning
algorithms inference algorithms and
learning algorithms that emerge ok so we
looked at several modeling paradigms
roughly broken into three categories the
first is state based model search
problems MVPs and games and here the the
way you think about modeling is in terms
of states and as nodes in a graph and
actions that take you between different
states which encourage their a cost or
give you some sort of reward and your
goal is just to find paths or contingent
paths or policies in these graphs then
we shifted gears to talk about variable
based models where instead we think
about variables and factors that
constrain or these variables to take on
certain types of values so in today's
lecture I'm going to talk about logical
based models so we're going to look at
propositional logic and first-order
logic which are two different types of
logical languages or models and we're
going to said think about logical
formulas and inference rules which is
going to be another way of kind of
thinking about modeling the world
historically logic was actually the
dominant paired
I mean AI before the 1990s so it might
be hard to kind of believe now but just
imagine the amount of excitement that is
going into deep learning today this
equal amount of excitement was going
into logical based methods and in AI and
in the 80s and before that too but there
was kind of two problems with logic one
is that logic was deterministic so we
didn't handle uncertainty very well and
that's why probabilistic inference and
other methods were developed to address
this and I was also rule-based which
allow didn't allow you to naturally
ingest a large amount of data to know
it's our guide behavior and the
emergence of machine learning has
addressed this but one strength that
kind of has been left on the table is
the expressiveness and I kind of
emphasize that logic as you will see
gives you the ability to express very
complicated things in a very you know
succinct way and that is kind of the
main point of logic which I really want
everyone to kind of appreciate and
hopefully this will become clear through
examples as I motivate on the first day
of class the reason one one good way to
think about why we might want logic is
imagine you want to lie on the beach and
you want your assistant to be able to do
things for you but hopefully it's more
like data from Star Trek rather than
Siri you want to take an assistant you
want to be able to at least tell the
information and ask your questions and
have these questions actually be
answered in response to reflect the
information that you've told them so
just kind of a brief refresher on the
first day of class I showed you this
demo where you can talk to the system
and say things and ask questions so a
small example is let's say all students
like CS 221 it's great and teach the
important things and Alice does not like
CS
twenty-one and then you can ask you know
is Alice a student and the answer should
be no because it can kind of reason
about this and just to dive in under the
hood a little bit inside it has some
sort of knowledge base that contains the
information that it has we'll come back
to this second okay so this this
assistant needs to be able to digest
heterogeneous information in the form of
natural language you know utterances and
it has to reason deeply with that
information so it can't just do
superficial pattern matching so I've
kind of suggested natural language as an
interface to this and natural language
is very powerful because I can stand up
here and use natural language to give a
lecture and hopefully you guys can
understand at least some of it and but
you know let's let's go with natural
language for now so here's an example of
how you can draw inferences using
natural language okay so a dime is
better than a nickel a nickel is better
than a penny so therefore a dime is
better than a penny okay so this seems
like pretty sound reasoning so what
about this example a penny is better
than nothing nothing is better than
world peace therefore a penny is better
than world peace right okay so something
clearly went wrong here and this is
because language is natural language is
kind of slippery it's not very precise
which makes it very easy to make these
these mistakes but if we step back and
think about what is the role of natural
language it's really language itself is
an exemplar expression so there are many
types of languages there's natural
languages
there's programming languages which all
you are you know familiar with but we're
going to talk about a different type of
language called logical languages like
program
images are gonna be formal so we're
gonna be absolutely clear what we mean
but when we have a statement in a
logical language but and like natural
language it's going to be declarative
and this is might be a little bit harder
to appreciate it right now but it's
means that there's kind of a more of a
one-to-one isomorphism between logical
languages and natural languages as are
compared to programming languages and
natural language okay so in a logical
language we want to have two properties
first the logical language should be
rich enough to represent knowledge about
the world and secondly it's not
sufficient just to represent the
knowledge because you know a hard drive
can represent the knowledge but you have
to be able to use that knowledge in a in
a way to reason with that a logic
contains three ingredients which I'll go
through in a in subsequent slides
there's a syntax which defines what kind
of expressions are valid or grammatical
in this language their semantics which
is for each expression or formula and
what does it mean and mean means is
actually mean something very precise
which I'll come back to and then
inference rules allow you to take
various formulas and do kind of
operations on them just like in the
beginning when we have the algebra
problem you can add equations you can
move things to different sides you can
perform these rules which are syntactic
manipulations on these formulas or
expressions that preserve some sort of
semantics okay so just to talk about
syntax versus semantics a little bit
because I think this might be a slightly
subtle point which hopefully will be
clear with this example
so syntax refers to
are the valid expressions in this
language and semantics is about what
these expressions mean so here is
example of two expressions which have
different syntax two plus three is not
the same thing as three plus two but
they have the same semantics both of
them mean the number you know five
here's a case where we have two
expressions with the same syntax 3/2 but
they have different semantics be
depending on which language you're at
okay so in order to define a language
precisely you not only have to specify
the syntax but also the the semantics
because just by looking at the syntax
you don't actually know what its meaning
is unless I tell you there's a bunch of
different logics the ones highlighted in
bold are the ones I'm gonna actually
talk about in this class so today's
lecture is going to be on propositional
logic and then in the next lecture I'm
going to look at first-order logic
as with most models in general there's
going to be a trade off between the
expressivity and the computational
efficiency so as I go down this list to
first-order logic and beyond I'm going
to be able to express more and more
things using the language but it's going
to be harder to do computation in that
language okay so this is the the kind of
a key diagram to have in your head while
I go through syntax semantics and
inference rules so for every I'm gonna
do this for propositional logic and then
in Monday's lecture I'm gonna do it for
first-order logic so just to get that on
the board we have syntax we have
semantics
then we have inference rules let's just
do so this lecture is going to have a
lot of definitions and concepts and just
to give you a warning there's a lot of
kind of ideas here they're all very kind
of simple by themselves and they kind of
piece together but there's just going to
kind of be a barrage of terms and I'll
try to write them on the board so that
you can kind of remember them so in
order to define a logic code language I
need to specify what are the formulas so
more maybe other comment about logic is
that some of you probably take in CS 103
or equivalent class we've been exposed
to propositional logic what I'm going to
do here is kind of a much more
methodological and rigorous treatment of
it there I want to distinguish the
difference between being able to do
logic yourself like if I gave you some
logical expression you can manipulate it
that's different than talking about the
general set of algorithms that can
operate on logic itself right so
remember in AI we're not interested in
you guys doing logic because that's just
I
that's intelligence but we're interested
in developing general principles or
general algorithms that can actually do
the work for you okay
just like in in the Bayesian networks
it's very fine well that you can you
guys can manipulate and condition
how cool a conditional marginal
probabilities your self but the whole
point is we devise algorithms like Gibbs
sampling and variable animation ation
that can work on any Bayesian network I
just want to
okay so let's begin this is going to be
building from the ground up so first of
all there are in propositional logic
there are a set of propositional symbols
these are typically going to be
uppercase letters or even words and
these are the atomic formulas these are
formulas that can't be any smaller there
is going to be logical connectives such
as not and or implication and
bi-directional implication and then the
set of formulas are built up recursively
so if F and G are formulas then I can
these are also formulas I can have not F
I can have F and G F or G F implies G M
F by directional implication G or
equivalent to G okay so key you know
ideas here are we have propositional
symbols I'm going to space so this these
are things like a there's that gives
rise to formulas in general which is
going to be denoted and so here are some
examples so a is a formula okay it's in
particular it's an atomic formula which
is a propositional symbol not a as a
formula not be implies C as a formula
this is a formula this is a formula
double negation is fine this is not a
formula because there's no connective
between a and not B this is also not a
formula because what the heck is plus
it's not a connective so so I think in
thinking about logic you really have to
divorce yourself from the common sense
that you all come with in interpreting
these symbols right not is just a symbol
or is just a symbol and they don't have
any semantics in fact I can go and
define some semantics which would be
completely different than what you
imagine it would be a valid Lodge
call system these are just symbols you
know I'm here defining is what symbols
are valid and what symbols are not valid
/ grammatical okay any questions about
the syntax of propositional logic so the
syntax gives you the set of formulas or
basically statements you can make so you
can think about as as this is our
language if we could only speak in
propositional logic I could say a or not
B or B or a implies C and that's all I
would be able to say and of course now I
have to tell you what do these things
mean okay and this is the realm of
semantics so semantics there's going to
be a number of definitions so first is a
model so this is really unfortunate and
confusing terminology but this is
standard in the logical literature so
I'm just going to use it so a model
which is different from our general
notion of a model for example hidden
Markov model for example a model here in
propositional logic just refers to an
assignment of truth values to
propositional symbols okay so if you
have three pops as you know symbols then
there are eight possible bottles a a is
1 B is 0 C is 0 for example so these are
just complete assignments that we saw
from factor graphs but now in this new
kind of language okay so that's the
first concept and the first two logic
models are going to be more complicated
but for now think about them as complete
that's and I'm using W because sometimes
you also call them worlds because a
complete assignment / a model is
supposed to represent the state of the
world at any one particular point in
time
yeah
yeah so the question is can each
propositional symbol either be true or
false and in logic as I'm presenting it
yes only true or false or zero one okay
so these are models and next is a key
thing that actually defines the
semantics which is the interpretation
function so the interpretation function
takes a formula and a model and returns
true if that formula is is true in this
model and false you know otherwise okay
so I can make the interpretation
function whatever I want and that just
gives me the semantics so when I talk
about what are the semantics it's the
interpretation function function I so
the way to think about this is I'm going
to represent formulas as these
horizontal bars okay so this is think
about this as a thing you say it sits
outside the reality and so in some sense
and then this box I'm going to draw on
the space of all possible models so
think about this is a space of
situations that we could be in the world
and a point here correspond to a
particular model so the interpretation
function takes one a formula takes a
model and says is this statement true if
the world look like this okay so just to
ground this out a little bit more I'm
going to define this for propositional
logic again recursively
so for propositional symbols P I'm just
going to interpret that propositional
symbol as a lookup in the model right so
if I'm asking hey is 8
why go to my model and I see well does
it say is true or false okay that's a
base case so recursively I can define
the interpretation of any formula in
terms of its sub formulas and the way I
do this is suppose I have two formulas F
and G and they're interpreted in some
way okay and now I take a formula let's
say F and G okay so what is the
interpretation of F and G in W well it's
given by this truth table so if F is 0
and G is interpreted to be 0 then F and
G is they also interpret to be 0 and 0 1
maps to 0 1 0 maps to 0 and 1 1 maps to
1 so you can verify that that's the kind
of your intuitive notion of what and
should be right or is 1 if at least one
of F and G or one implication is 1 if F
is 0 or G is is is one if bi-directional
implication just means that if F and G
evaluate to the same thing not F is no
clearly just you know negation of
whatever the interpretation of F is ok
so this slide gives you the full
semantics of propositional logic there's
nothing more to propositional logic and
at least the definition of what it is
aside for this let me go through an
example and then I'll maybe take
questions so so let's look at this
formula not a.m. be bi-directional
implication see and this model a is 1 B
is 1 C is 0 how do I interpret this
formula against this model well I look
at the the tree which breaks down the
formula so if I look at the leaves let's
start
so the interpretation of a against W is
just one because for proposition symbols
I just look up what a is and a is one
here
the interpretation of not a is zero
because if I look back at this table if
this evaluates to 1 then this evaluates
to zero I'm just looking based on the
table B is 1 just by the table lookup
and then not a and B is 0 because I just
take these two values and I and them
together C is 0 by table lookup and then
bi-directional implication is
interpreted as 1 here because 0 is yeah
question function is yeah so the
question is is the interpretation
functions user-defined it is just
written down this is it there's no
learning that's just these are this is
what you get it's not user defined in a
sense that not everyone's going to go to
find their own you know truth table is
some logicians came up with this and
that's what it is
but you could define your own logics and
it's kind of a fun thing start doing ok
any other questions about interpretation
functions and models so now we're kind
of connecting syntax and semantics right
so an interpretation function binds what
our formulas which are in syntax land to
a notion of models which are in
semantics so a lot of logic is very it
might seem a little bit pedantic but
it's just because we're trying to be
very rigorous in a way that doesn't need
to appeal to your common sense
intuitions about what these formulas
okay any questions all right so so while
we have the interpretation function and
it defines everything it's really going
to be useful to think about formulas in
a slightly different way so we're gonna
think about the formula as representing
on the set of all models for which
interpretation is true okay
so M of F which is this is the set of
models that F is true on that model
okay so pictorially this is a f that you
say out loud and what you mean by this
is simply this subset of models which
this F is true okay so if I make a
statement here what I'm really saying is
that I think we're in one of these
models and not in one of these other
models so that's a kind of an important
I think intuition to have the meaning of
a formula is carving out a space of
possible situations that you can be you
guys say there's a water bottle on the
table what I'm really saying is that I'm
ruling out all the possible worlds we
could be in where there is no water
table bottle on the table
okay so models of F is going to be a
subset of all the possible models in a
while okay
so here's an example so if I say it's
either raining or wet rain or what then
the set of models can be represented by
this subset of this two-by-two okay so
over here I have rain over here I've wet
so this corresponds to no rain but it's
outside this corresponds to it's raining
but it's not white outside and the set
of models F is this red region which are
these three possible models okay so I'm
gonna use this kind of pictorial
depiction throughout this lecture so
hopefully this makes sense so the one
key idea here remember I said that logic
allows you to express very complicated
and large things by using very small
means so here I have a very small
formula that's able to represent a set
of models and that set of models could
be exponentially large and much of the
power of logic allow it comes from the
ability to do stuff like that
okay so here's yet another definition
this one's not somehow such a new
definition sorry a new concept but it's
kind of just trying to give us a little
bit more intuition for what these
formulas and models are doing so a
knowledge base is just a set of formulas
and think about this is the set of facts
you know about the world so this is what
you have in your head and in general
it's going to be us just a set of
formulas and now the the key thing is I
need to connect this with semantics so
I'm going to define the set of models
denoted by a knowledge base to be the
intersection of all the models to notify
the formulas so in this case if I brain
or snow being this green ellipse and
traffic being this red ellipse then the
model is denoted by the knowledge base
is just the intersection okay so you can
think about knowledge is how fine-grain
we've kind of zoomed in on where we are
in the world right so initially you
don't know anything we say anything is
possible all to to the end no models are
possible and as you add formulas into
your knowledge base
a set of possible worlds that you think
might eggs are possible is going to
shrink and you know we'll see that in
this in a second ok so here's an example
of a knowledge base if so have rain that
corresponds is this set of models rain
implies what corresponds to this set of
models and if I look at the models of
this knowledge base is just going to be
the intersection which is this red
square down here ok any questions about
knowledge bases models interpretation
functions so far alright so as I've
alluded to earlier knowledge base is the
thing you're having had and as you go
through life you're going to add more
formulas to your knowledge base you're
gonna learn more things so your
knowledge base just gets a union with
whatever formula you have and over time
the set of models is going to shrink
because you're just taking an
intersection and one question is you
know how much is this shrinking okay so
here there's a bunch of different cases
to contemplate the first case is
entailment so suppose this is your
knowledge base so far and then someone
tells you the formula that corresponds
to this set here ok so in this case
intuitively f doesn't add any
information or new constraints that was
known before in particularly if you take
the intersection of these two you end up
with exactly the same set of models you
had before so you didn't learn anything
and this is called entailment
so there's kind of three notions here
there's entailment
which is written this way with two
horizontal bars which means that the set
of models of F is at least as large as
the set of models and KT or in other
words it's a superset okay so for
example rain and snow if you already
knew it was raining and snowing someone
tells you I it's snowing then you say
well I didn't learn anything a second
case is contradiction so if you believe
the world to be in here somewhere
and someone told you it's actually out
here then your brain explodes right so
this is where the set of models of the
knowledge base and the set of models
denoted by the formula is empty so it
doesn't make sense okay so that's a
contradiction okay so if you knew I was
rainy and snowy and someone says it's
actually not snowing then you if you
like know that that count that can't be
right okay so the third case is
basically everything else its
contingency where F adds a non-trivial
amount of information to a knowledge
base so the the new set of models the
intersection here is neither empty nor
is it the original knowledge base
one thing to kind of not get confused by
is if the set of models were actually
strictly inside the knowledge base that
would also be your contingency right
because when you're intersected it's
neither empty nor the original okay so
if you knew was grainy ants raining and
someone said oh it's also snowing too
then you're like oh cool I learned
something okay so there's a relationship
between contradiction entailment so
contradiction says that the knowledge
base and F R have zero intersection and
entailment this is equivalent to the
knowledge base in tailing not F okay so
justjust there's a simple proposition
that says K be contradicts F if KP fan
fkb entails not out okay so this is a
picture you should have in here is like
naught F is all the models which are not
in this and you think about kind of
wrapping that around it kind of looks
like this okay all right so with these
three notions entailment contradiction
and contingency which are relationships
between a knowledge base and new formula
we can now go back to our kind of
virtual assistant example and think
about how to implement these operations
so if I have a knowledge base and I tell
the the virtual assistant of a
particular formula F there are three
possible abilities which correspond to
different appropriate responses so if I
say it's raining
then if it's in the Tillman and I say I
renew that because I didn't learn
anything new if it's a contradiction
then I should say I don't believe that
because it's not consistent with my
knowledge so far and otherwise you learn
something okay
there's also the ask operation which if
you're asking a question again the same
three entailment contradiction and
contingency can hold but now the
responses are should be answers this
question so if it's in Tillman then I
say yes and this is a strong yes and
it's not like probably yes this is a
definitely yes if it's a contradiction
then I say no it's again it's a strong
no it's impossible and then in the other
case it's just contingent which you say
I don't know okay so the answer to a yes
or no question there's three responses
not two okay okay
any questions about this how many of you
are following along okay good all right
so this is a little bit of a digression
and it's going to connect to Bayesian
networks so you might be thinking in
your head well we kind of did something
like this already right when Bayesian
networks we had these complete
assignments and we actually define joint
distributions over a complete
assignments and and now what we're
talking about is not distributions but
sets of assignments or models and so we
can actually think about the relation
between a knowledge base and F also
having an analog
in a Bayesian network land given by this
formula so remember a knowledge base is
a set of models or possible worlds so in
the probabilistic terms is an event and
that event has some probability so
that's that's a denominator here and
when you look at F and KB and you
intersect them you get some other event
which is a subset of that and you can
ask for the probability mass of that
intersect event that's the numerator
here and you divide those that actually
just gives you the probability of a
formula or given the knowledge base okay
so this is actually a kind of pretty
nice and direct probabilistic
generalization of in a propositional
logic yeah you have like all the
variables required for that formula
already exist in your set of world so
like in this scenario there's a PCP
we were asking something about D would
still be and I don't know because yeah
so the question is this only works when
restricted to the set of predefined
propositional symbols and you asked
about D then yeah you would say I don't
know and it's in fact when you define
propositional logic you have to pre
specify the set of symbols that you're
dealing with in in general yeah we did
earlier like reading wasn't in the set
of examples or things that our agent
knew about before we started like
training yeah so the question is in the
in the in practice you could imagine
giving an agent like it is raining or
it's snowing or sleeting and having
novel concepts it is true that you can
divide build systems and the system I'm
showing you has that capability and this
is it will be clear how we do that when
we talk about inference rules because
that allows
to operate directly on the syntax here
I'm talking about semantics where you
essentially just just for convenience I
mean you can be smarter but but we're
just defining the world yeah yeah so in
this formula why is this Union and not
intersection so I'm Union in the KB with
a formula which is equivalent to
intersecting the models of the KB with
the models of the formula okay so this
is a number between 0 & 1 and this
reduces actually to the logical case if
if this probability of 0 um
that means there's a contradiction right
because this intersection is it's going
to be positive probably zero and if it's
1 that means in its entailment and the
cool thing is that instead of just
saying I don't know you can actually
give a probabilistic estimate of I could
well I don't know but it's probably like
90% so you know we're not going to talk
this is all I'm gonna say about
probabilistic intentions to logic but
there are a bunch of other things that
you can do that kind of marry the
expressive power of logic with some of
the more advanced capability of handling
uncertainty of probabilities yeah
assuming that we above the distribution
yeah to do this you were assuming that
we actually have the Joint Distribution
ahead and a separate problem is of
course learning this so for logic I'm
only talking about inference I'm not
going to talk about learning although
there are ways to actually infer logical
expressions - ok so back from the
digression now we know probably always
any more we're just going to talk about
logic there's another concept which is
really useful called satisfiability
and this is going to allow us to
implement
entailment contradiction contingency
using kind of one primitive and the
definition is the knowledge base is
satisfiable if the set of models is non
empty okay so it's not self
contradictory in other words so now we
can reduce asking tell to satisfy them
okay remember ask and tell have three
possible outcomes if I ask a satisfiable
question how many possible outcomes are
there two so how am I going to make this
work I have to probably call satisfiable
twice okay so let's start with asking if
knowledge-based Union not F is
satisfiable or not okay so if the answer
is no what can I conclude
so remember the answer is no so it's not
satisfiable which means that KB
contradicts not F and what is that
equivalent to saying sorry yeah so it's
not F so it's which one of these is it
should it be a tail meant contradiction
or contingency yeah so I'm interested in
relation feeding KB and F I'm asking the
question about KB Union not F
yeah yeah yeah so exactly so this should
be an intimate relation between KB and
remember
KB entails F is equivalent to KB
contradicting not okay okay so what
about if it's yes then I can ask another
question is KB Union F satisfied so the
answer is no then what should I say it
should be a contradiction because I mean
this literally says KB contradicts F and
then finally if it's yes then its
contingency okay so this is a way in
which you can reduce answering ask and
tell which is basically about assessing
entailment contradiction or contingency
to just two at most two satisfiability
calls so why are we reducing things to
satisfy ability for propositional logic
checking satisfiability is just the
classical sap problem is actually a
special case of solving constraint
satisfaction problems and the mapping
here is
we just call propositional symbols
variables formulas constraints and we
get an assignment here and we call that
a model so in this case if you have a
knowledge base like this then there are
three variables a B and C and we define
this CSP and then we can if we find a
satisfying assignment then then we
return satisfiable if we can't find one
then we return on that okay so this is
called model checking
it's called mono checking because we're
checking whether a model exists or is
it's true so you malting takes a
knowledge base and outputs whether
there's a satisfying model there are a
bunch of algorithms here which are you
know very popular to something called
DPI all named after for four people and
this is essentially backtracking search
plus a pruning that takes into account
the structure of your CSPs which are
propositional logic formulas and there's
something called walks ad which is you
can think about the closest analogue
that we've seen is Gibbs sampling which
is a randomized local search ok so at
this point you really can have all the
ingredients you need to do inference in
propositional logic so you define what
propositional logic symbols are or
formulas are I define the semantics and
I've told you even how to solve
entailment and contradiction and
contingency queries by reducing the
satisfiability which is actually
something we've already you know seen
coincident away so that should be it ok
but now coming back to the original
motivation of X 1 plus X 2 equals 10 and
how we were able to perform that logical
query much faster we can ask the
question now can we exploit that that
the factors are our formulas rather than
arbitrary functions and this is where
inference rules is going to come into
play
ok so so I'll try to explain this figure
a little bit since this was probably
pretty mysterious from the beginning so
I have a bunch of formulas this my
knowledge base over time I accrue
formulas and these formulas carve out a
set of models in semantics land and and
this formula here if it's a super set
that means it's entailed by these
formulas right so I know that this is
true given my knowledge which means that
this is kind of a logical consequence of
what I know
ok so so far what we talked about is
taking formulas and doing everything
over in semantics land what I'm going to
talk about now is inference rules that
are going to allow us to directly
operate on the syntax and hopefully get
some results that way ok so here is an
example of making an inference so if I
say it is raining and I tell you if it's
raining it's wet rain implies what then
what should you be able to conclude it's
wet right so I'm gonna write this
integer all this way with this kind of
fraction looking like thing where
there's a set of premises which is a set
of formulas which I know to be true and
if those things were true then I can
derive a conclusion which is another
formula this is an instance of a general
rule called modus ponens
this says for any propositional symbols
P and Q if I have
P & P implies Q in my knowledge base
then I can that entails uh Q okay so
let's talk about its rules
I'm sure let me do it over here
space otherwise okay so modus ponens is
a first thing we're going to talk about
so notice here that if I could do these
type images it's much less work right
because I it's very localized I all I
have to do is look at these three
formulas I don't have to care about all
the other formulas or problem symbols
that exist and going back to this
question over here about oh how do I
what happens if I have new concepts that
occur well you can just treat everything
as it's just a new symbol there's not
necessary a fixed set of symbols that
you're working with at any given time
okay so this is the example of an
infant's role in general the idea of the
inference rule is that you have rules
that say if I see f1 through FK which
are formulas then I can add you and the
key idea as I mentioned before is that
in these inference rules operate
directly on the syntax and not on the
semantics so given a bunch of inference
rules I have this kind of meta algorithm
that can do logical inference as follows
so I have a set of inference rules and
I'm just going to repeat until there's
no changes to a knowledge base I choose
a set of formulas from the knowledge
base
if I find a matching rule inside rules
that exists then I simply add G to the
knowledge base okay so what
the other definition I'm gonna make is
this idea of derives improved so
inference rule derives proves so I'm
gonna write KB and now with a single
horizontal line to mean that from this
knowledge base given a set of inference
rules I can produce F via the rules okay
this is in contrast to entailment which
is defined by the relationship between
the models of KB and the models of F now
this is just a function of mechanically
applying a set of rules okay so that's a
very very important distinction and if
you think about it why is it called
proof so whenever you do a mathematical
proof or some sort of logical argument
you're in sense in some sense just doing
a logical inference where you have some
premises and then you can apply some
rule for example you can add you know
multiply both sides of the equation by
two that's a rule you can apply it and
you get some other equation in which you
can which you hope is true as well okay
so here's an example
maybe I'll just for fun I'll do it over
here
so I can say it is raining and if I dump
that it gives me my knowledge base it
has rain if it is raining it is wet so
if I dump then I have this is the same
as rain implies wet okay
just is just in case you're rusty on
your propositional logic if I have P
implies Q that's the same as not P or Q
and notice that I have also wet up here
in my knowledge base because this in the
background it's basically running
forward inference to try to derive as
many conclusions as I can ok and if I
say if it is wet it is slippery again
now I have I have wet imply slippery and
now I also derive slippery I also derive
rain implies slippery which is actually
as you've seen not drivable from modus
ponens so behind the scenes is actually
a much more fancy inference algorithm
but but but the idea here is that you
have your knowledge base you can pick up
rain and rain implies when and then you
can add wet and you pick up ray wet wet
implies slippery and then you've got
slippery here and with modus ponens you
can't actually derive some things you
can't derive not wet which is probably
good because it's not true and you also
can't arrive rain imply slippery which
actually is true but our modus ponens is
not powerful enough to derive it ok so
so the burning question you should have
in your head is ok I talked about
there's two relations between a
knowledge base KB and a formula F there
is the entailment relation and this is
really what you want
because this is semantics you care about
meaning and you also have this KB
derives F which is a syntactic
relationship so what's a connection here
in general there's no connection but
there's kind of these concepts that will
help us think about the connection so if
it's semantics these are things which
are when you look at semantics you think
about the models
implied by the the formulas and syntax
is just some set of rules that someone
made up okay so how do these relate okay
so to understand this imagine you have a
class and this class is what's inside
the class is a formulas and in
particular it's the formulas which are
true okay so this class is all formulas
such that the this formula is entailed
by the knowledge base so soundness is a
property of a set of rules and it says
if I apply these rules until the end of
time do I stay within the class am I
always going to generate formulas which
are inside the class which are
semantically valid or until okay so
soundness is good completeness says the
the kind of other direction which says
that I am going to generate all the
formulas which are true or entail am i
generating extra stuff but at least I'll
cover everything that's why it means to
be complete okay so the model you should
have in your head is you want the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth
soundness is really about nothing but
the truth and completeness is about the
whole truth ideally you would want both
sometimes you can't have both so you're
gonna have to pick your battles but
generally you want soundness you can
maybe live without completeness but if
you're unsound that means you're just
going to generate erroneous conclusions
which is bad whereas if you're
incomplete then maybe you just kept in
for certain notions but at least you the
things that you do in for
you know are actually true okay so how
do we check soundness
so is modus ponens sound so remember
there's kind of a rigorous way to do
this and the rigorous way is to look at
two formulas rain rain implies wet and
then look at their models
okay so rain corresponds to these set of
models here rain implies what
corresponds to this set and when I
intersect them that's the set of models
which are conveyed by the knowledge base
which is this corner here and I have to
check whether that is a subset of the
models of wet and what is over here so
this one one corner is a subset of 1 1
and 0 1 so this rule is sounded
remember this why is this subset the
thing I want to check because that's
just the definition of entailment right
okay so let's do another example so if
someone said it was wet and you know
that rainy implies wet can you infer a
rain well let's let's just double check
this okay so again what are the models
of wet they're here one of the models of
rain implies wet they're here and I
intersect them I get this um this these
two over here in dark red and then is
that a subset of models of rain nope so
this is on south okay so when general
soundness is actually a fairly easy
condition to check especially in
propositional logic but in higher order
logics it's not as bad so now
completeness is a kind of a different
story which I'm not going to have time
to really do full justice in this class
but but here's a kind of an example
showing modus ponens is incomplete so
for proposition of logic so here we have
the knowledge base rain rain or snow
implies wet and is this entailed wet
so it's raining and if I know it's
raining or snowing then it should be wet
how many really say yes yeah it should
be entailed right okay but what is the
modus ponens do well all the rules look
like this so clearly you can't actually
arrive at this with modus ponens because
modus ponens can't reason about or or
disjunction yeah that's the reader still
I'm saying that it's not possible for it
to not wet given rain is yeah because
you're you already know that's raining
right so you should say that's okay so
this is incomplete so we can be you know
sad about this there are two ways you
can go to fix this the first way is we
say okay okay propositional logic was
too fancy question yeah the notation
when it says VB equals rain then comma
brainer snow it's wet is it him finding
any type of assignment to ring their
like is it saying that he is raining or
is it just saying that we have the
variable rate yeah so the question is
what does this mean this so the
knowledge base is a set of formulas so
in this particular formula is rain and
remember the models of a knowledge base
is where the formulas are true so yes in
this case it does commits to rain being
one then models of KBR only include the
the models where rain is one otherwise
this formula would be false yeah
oh it was how can we have a probability
over a model so remember that a model is
where to go
okay so remember a model here is just an
assignment to a set of proposition
symbols or variables right so when we
talk about Bayesian networks we're
defining a distribution over assignments
to all the variables so here what I'm
saying is I assume there is some
distribution over complete assignments
to random variables and I can use that
to compute probability queries of the
form formula given knowledge base might
answer your question they can't be in
the same knowledge base if you have two
models that or formulas that contradict
then this intersection is going to be
zero
so there is exists a set of models so
let me do it this way so imagine you
have these two variables rain and wet a
Bayesian network might assign a
probability point 1 the point I should
make these sum to one point what is this
5 so some distribution over these states
right and and if I have rain that
corresponds to these models so I can
write the probability of rain is 0.2
plus 0.5 0.7 okay and if I have the
probability of wet given rain this is
going to be the probability of the
conjunction of these
which is going to be what and rain which
is here it's going to be 0.5 divided by
the probability of rain which is 0.7
does that help
okay oops okay so okay so modus ponens a
sound but it's not complete so there's
two things we can do about this we can
either say propositional logic is too
fancy let's just restrict it so that
modus ponens becomes complete with with
respect to restrict a set of formulas or
we can use more powerful infants rules
so today we're going to restrict
propositional logic to make it complete
and then next time we're going to show
how a resolution which is even more
powerful in ritual can be used to make
any arbitrary inferences and this is
what's powering the system that I show
you okay so few more definitions so
we're going to define you know logic
with with horn clauses okay so so a
definite Clause is a propositional
formula of the following form so you
have some propositional symbols all
conjoined together or join just means
it's ANDed implies some other
propositions in both Q and the intuition
of this formula says if P 1 through P
call K hold them Q also holds so here
are some examples
rain and snow implies traffic traffic is
can be as possible this is an awning
example this is a valid propositional
logic formula but it's not a valid
definite clause
here's also another example rain and
snow implies peace traffic or peaceful
okay so this is not allowed because only
thing allowed on the rights and I on
side of the implication is a single
propositional symbol and there's two
things over here okay so a horn Clause
is a definite clause or a goal clause
which might seem a little bit mysterious
but it's defined as a something that P 1
through P K implies false and the way to
think about this is the negation of a
conjunction of things right because
remember P implies Q is not P or Q so
this would be not P or true which is not
P in this case okay so so now we have
these horn clauses now remember the
inference rule modus ponens we are going
to slightly generalize this to include
not just P implies Q but P 1 through P K
implies Q so you get to match on
premises which include formulas which
are atomic propositional symbols and the
rule that looks like this and you can
derive or prove Q from that okay so as
an example wet and weekday if you see
wet weekday wet and we K implies traffic
those three formulas then you can you're
able to add traffic okay so so here's
the claim so modus ponens is complete
with respect to horn clauses for
propositional logic so in other words
what this means is that
suppose that the knowledge base contains
only horn clauses and that P is some
entailed propositional symbol by the
entail propositional symbol imeem like
KB actually entails Pisa matically then
apply modus ponens will derive P means
that the two relations are equivalent
and you can celebrate because you have
both soundness and our completeness okay
so just a quick example of this so here
imagine is your knowledge base and
you're asking the question is there
traffic and remember because this is a
set of only horn clauses and we're using
modus ponens which is complete that
means entailment is the same as i'll be
able to derive it using these rules this
particular rule and you would do it in a
following way so rain rain implies what
gives you what what weekday wet and
weekday implies traffic gives you
traffic and then you're done yeah - like
rain and bky are those one causes the
question is why are rain and we take
horn clauses so if you look at the
definition of horn clauses they're
definite clauses to look at the definite
issue of death then the clauses they
look like this and K can be 0 here which
means that there's this kind of like
nothing
that make sense yes it's a little bit
look I'm using this notation kind of to
exploit this corner case that if you
have the an of zero things then that's
just true or you can just say by
definition definite clauses contain
propositional symbols that would do it
too okay so let me try to give you some
intuition why modus ponens and horn
clauses so the way you can think about
modus ponens is that it only works with
positive and information in sometimes
there's no branching either or it's like
every time you see this you just
definitively declare Q to be true so in
your knowledge base you're just going to
build up all these prophecies or symbols
that you know are going to be true and
the only way you can add a new problems
is your symbol ever is by matching a set
of other things which you can definitely
know to be true and some rule that tells
you you should be true and then you make
you true I have Q to your knowledge base
as well the problem with problems you
know some of the more general causes is
if you look at this rain and snow
implies traffic or peaceful you can't
just write down traffic or or peaceful
or both of them you have to reason about
well it could be either one and that is
outside the scope of what modus ponens
can do yeah and
oh yeah yeah good good question so what
if happens if it were traffic and
peaceful so this is an interesting case
where technically it's not a definite
clause but it essentially is so there's
a few subtleties here so if you have a
implies B and C you can rewrite that
this is exactly the same as having two
formulas a implies B and a implies C and
these are definite clauses just like you
know technically if I gave you hey what
about a not a or B it's not a definite
Clause by the definition but you can
rewrite that as a implies B so there is
slight kind of you can extend this to
say not only definite clauses but all
things which are morally form clauses
right where you can do a little bit of
rewriting and then you get a honk laws
and then you can do your friends okay so
resolution is this inference rule that
we'll look at next time that allows us
to deal with these disjunctions okay so
to wrap up so today we talked about
logic so logic has three pieces we
introduced the syntax for propositional
logic you have propositional symbols
which you string together into formulas
in over in syntax land these are given
meaning by talking about you know
semantics and we introduced an idea of a
model which is a particular
configuration of world that you can be
in a formula denotes a set of models
which are true under that formula this
is given by an interpretation function
then we looked at entailment
contradiction and contingency which are
relations between a knowledge base and a
new formula that you might pick up you
can either do satisfiability check a
model
checking which test for satisfiability
to solve that or you can actually do
things in syntax lam by just operating
directly on impure tools so that's all I
have for today and I'll see you next
Monday